[Aplausos]
estamos aquí para seguir con Nuestro
objetivo de conservar la revolución
islámica Nadie puede destruir nuestra
Revolución
el 4 de noviembre es uno de esos eventos
pilares de la república islámica se
realiza enfrente de lo que fue la
embajada estadounidense y miles de
estudiantes son traídos aquí en un día
que han llamado el día de los
estudiantes Esta es una ocasión es
obviamente especial no solamente porque
es el día que vienen a recordar aquí
frente a miles otros estudiantes que
están protestando en las calles en los
Colegios y en las universidades sino que
para nosotros los periodistas es el
único día que nos han dejado salir a la
calle a grabar esto que ustedes están
viendo detrás de mí el
han sido imposibles demostrar
estos disturbios ponen en peligro la
seguridad del país no estamos en contra
de que las personas expresen su
inconformidad pero sí estamos en contra
de los disturbios
lo normal en esta celebración es que se
canten eslabones en contra de los
enemigos de Irán especialmente Estados
Unidos
pero bien especial ha terminado
convertido en una demostración de apoyo
al régimen habla al presidente Ibrahim
Racing por primera vez no hablan los
presidentes en esta conmemoración y
llega un día después en que han vuelto a
tomar aire las protestas en al menos
siete ciudades del país Recordando a
cientos de personas que han sido
asesinadas durante estas protestas que
aquí no son llamadas como personas que
piden por sus derechos muchos de ellos
son identificados como vándalos y así
los llaman muchas de las personas que
están aquí donde también se recuerdan al
menos 15 personas tres de ellos niños
que murieron en un ataque a una mezquita
enchilada se fue a traer a veces se lo
reclamó como
sin embargo aquí en algunos otros
lugares de Irán también recuerdan al
menos 40 niños que han muerto durante
estas protestas